Hey everyone, how's it going? My name is Mayuko, and welcome
back to my channel. So I realize that it's July, which means
that a lot of you have recently graduated college. And it
made me think of the time in my own life when I graduated,
and I kind of just had no idea how to adult exactly all
throughout college. And like, even when I was in high
school, applying to college, I feel like there was just like
so many resources and pamphlets and stuff around me about
how to do college. There were like seminars and things that
kind of all explained, like how you get into college, and
then what do you do when you're there, and how to make the
most of your experience. And getting in these days is like
such a hard part of the process. Like it's gotten even more
competitive over the last few years. So if you're applying
to college right now, I feel for you, and once you get to
college, however way you might get there, a lot of things
are kind of set up for you. There's orientation events and
icebreakers and roommate finders, and then throughout the
year, they provide like academic and career counseling. And
they also show you like where's the best place to eat on
campus or whatever. There's clubs and organizations that you
can join with, like built in socialization, which makes it
really easy to make friends college is like a super nice
sleepaway camp or something. Except, of course, it costs
about as much as a private jet to attend. And as you get
ready to head off to college, you've probably heard a lot of
like this proverbial college wisdom from just about everyone
around you. They'll give you a little tips and wax poetic,
like how college is going to be so different from anything
you've ever experienced in your life, you're not going to be
able to get away with not studying in college, you better
get ready for all the costs and all nighters, it's gonna be
different in college, Just you wait. But the really crazy
part is gonna be the party scene. And all of this adds up to
the point that like when you're going to college, even if
you're a little bit nervous, you just have so much
information and advice at your fingertips that you kind of
know what to expect. But then college comes to an end. And
it feels like in contrast to all the advice you got in going
to college, you get not nearly as much advice and wisdom
about life after college, that crowd of wisdom givers and
well wishers basically go silent. And that's the problem.
Because as difficult as college is for some people, what we
really all need help with is what comes next, everyone talks
about college in the same way. Because everyone who's gone
to college knows more or less what it's like. It's one of
the last real shared experiences that people can hold on to,
before they scatter to the wind after graduation. After
graduation. People do so many different things with their
life, some of your friends graduate and immediately get
married and somehow buy a house within like a year. Others
grow their hair long and live in a van for 18 months. And
everyone in between does something slightly different
traveling fancy jobs, finding themselves settling down, or
none of the above. So you can't really make a pamphlet or
like a pre written wise quote, for the wild variety of post
college experiences. The closest we get to any proverbial
wisdom with all of that are kind of like means that your
cousin posts about like adulting on Facebook every once in a
while. It's like people's experience vary so much that it's
kind of impossible to prescribe, like general blanket advice
that works for everybody. So no one kind of bothers I
suppose that's understandable. But sometimes it does feel a
little intentional, like what it feels like sometimes it's
like, Okay, bye Good luck with your life. But there are such
intense things that happen after college. In fact, nearly
all the difficulties we face things like emotional stress,
financial stress, like big moves in career in life and
stuff. They all happen after college. So naturally, one of
the biggest things that I've heard from lots of people in
their 20s, including myself is something called post college
disillusionment, where colleges is like super magical
moment, and everything's fun and super challenging. And
you're just like, wow, there's like so much that the world
and life has to offer, that after you graduate and you step
out into the real world, it somehow feels a little
disappointing. But it doesn't have to be that way. I think
that life after college is without a doubt the best part of
life. Or at least it can be because life after college can
be anything. You'd also love something like 80 years and
college last for so it'd be smart to make the ad as good as
before or better. So what do you do after college? What
happens next? And what are some mindsets that are really
helpful to have as you move into the longest phase of your
life? Well, let's start with the positive is that you get to
design your own life. There's a day that happens after your
graduation ceremony after all the events and work
requirements like meetings and stuff are over, after
everyone is finished congratulating you, and basically going
back to their lives where you wake up in the bed and realize
that you're totally on your own. There's no one to really
tell you what to do no classes to go to no homework, no
dining, all, nothing. And you'll come to realize that there
are literally going to be hundreds of those days. And you
have to ask yourself, what are you going to do with them?
That's one of the weirdly scary things about post college
life is the first time we're given the opportunity to truly
design and build your lives from the ground up. And it can
feel overwhelming. But if you approach it kind of slowly,
and like systematically, that freedom can turn into the best
thing ever. And you'll come to really appreciate it like I
think it's a blessing in disguise, take my word for it, I've
been adulting for a while, and it gets easier. So let's take
it step by step. There's your work life and your personal
life, both of which are obviously important for different
reasons. Inside of those are things like your mental and
physical health, and ways to spend time like hobbies and a
social life, you likely actually already has some sort of
structure that worked for you in college, obviously, it's
going to be changing a lot now. But think of the systems and
structures that you liked, and really helped you. And kind
of build off of that, because you already have something you
can work off of. And that's going to give you like a bit of
stability and familiarity during this time. So let's start
with work. Maybe you work full time, or maybe you're
freelance, but either way, you get to decide how much of
your life you want to spend on work. So what do you want
your work life to look like? a strict nine to five? Or are
you more of a 12 hour day hustler that wants work to be a
bigger part of their life? Do you want to invest all of your
energy into work, or do just enough to succeed? Both options
are totally valid, of course, you just have to choose which
one you like. Or if you prefer something in between, like
you can log off at 5pm or invest a few more hours per day
and stay on longer to build your foundational work skills.
And this plays right into figuring out your own personalized
work life balance. Or in other words, how do you want to
balance your work life from your personal life. And I gotta
say, I know it's easy to like go full throttle when you're
first start work. But I really encourage you to pay
attention to your body and mind during this time, when they
feel out of sorts, like definitely take a break. We might
not really know or like max capacity yet. But we all know
what it feels to be overextended and overwhelmed. So take
some pre emptive steps like check in with yourself to make
sure that you don't get there, the things you do in both
parts of your life will influence how the other feels. So
find out what works well for you. Maybe it's a glass of
water in the morning, a walk break in the middle of the day,
eating a healthy lunch, or turning off your email
notifications after work, which is what I do. And nobody
getting an email from me after five o'clock. It does take
like actual work to manage your own energy and times that
you have plenty of both in and outside of work. So just be
patient in figuring out what works for you. Remember,
though, that you get to decide what your balance looks like.
So when it comes to personal life, one such shift that
you're probably going to feel from college life is
maintaining a social life. This might be like the first time
in your life, which I know it was for me, where you can't
rely on the built in socialization systems that existed in
school, you used to be with people your age around you all
the time, whether that be like in class or like you lived in
the dorms or whatever. But now everyone's in a different job
and maybe even in different cities. And it's easy to fall in
a pattern of going to work going home and going to work
again with like nothing in between. If you're super outgoing
and social in college, don't be surprised if you start to
feel a little lonely especially as things start out. But
it's totally possible to build an entirely new network of
friends after college and just like everything else in the
strange new life, it's all completely up to you. I've
actually found that like post college it's kind of easier to
make friends maybe it's because people in your same age
range are like easy to talk to and like the superficial
cliques and like clubs and stuff that existed in school kind
of start to melt away when you're an adult you know once you
get the hang of it it becomes really easy to find common
ground with like people in kind of your age group because
you've experienced similar things before and I think part of
why it becomes easier to make friends is like everybody's
just trying to make it work like life's hard for everyone
and like no one cares anymore about things like cliques and
stuff and you know if making friends take some time that's
okay too. You don't need to immediately find like your best
friend five ever right away.
Because I found that in adulthood, like connections and like
how you meet friends like becomes increasingly web like, as
in I meet like one person, and then they introduced me to
like two other people, and then it kind of like spiders out
from there. Of course, it won't be as easy to actually find
time to hang out because of like work and like other life
things. But it is possible. I think we all know, especially
after this long quarantine, that in the age of the internet,
geographic constraints are not a big deal. When it comes to
maintaining friendships, just give it a little effort,
schedule your Hangouts and utilize your weekends when you
can, you'll be glad you did. So once you start working on
your baseline, and you start feeling like both your work and
personal life is like starting to get kind of like a good
balance or like you're on your way, then you might start
thinking about your life in kind of more of a macro sense.
And even though it might be scary, it's kind of a good time
to start thinking about what life you want to live, and what
kind of effort Do you need to put in to make that happen.
And one of the most important things I've learned after
graduating from college is that you get out what you put in,
there's a version of your life where like, you're pretty
happy, you have a pretty stable job, you enjoy your normal
life, but you feel like you're not quite as happy as you
could be. And if you don't want to live like that, it's up
to you to put in the effort to make your life better. The
difference between like your pre adulting life and now is
that you're 100% responsible for how you want to use your
energy in life, in all of the energy you put into something
is going to be all the energy you get out of something, if
that makes sense. Sure, school is also kind of like that
though. If you put in more effort, you'll probably learn
more and get better grades. But there isn't a syllabus
anymore. There aren't calendars and guides for how exactly
to spend your time, no one's gonna make decisions for you or
give you what you need unless you work for it. So you have
to figure out a lot on your own. Now, for a lot of you, I
know this is going to be like the first time you're ever
steering your ship. And I know that can be really scary and
daunting, but I assure you, it gets better with time, just
move towards the things that mean something to you or bring
goodness to your life in some way. For example, start to
think about like routines that you want to build into your
life that will benefit you like focusing on exercising or
your nutrition. Okay, so I want to make an assumption here
about you all, college probably took care of like food for
you, you might have had a meal card and like a cafeteria and
like different dining halls, you could go to at like 2am.
And as a result, it's likely and totally fine if all you can
make is like butter noodles. And like garlic bread. I'm also
sorry if that's the wrong assumption. I'm just making an
assumption here for the video. But I have to say there are
some serious advantages that come with being able to cook
your own food, you're more in control than you've ever been
before, like the health content and like choosing what goes
into your food and like choosing what you want to eat when
you get to like cook when you want and add the ingredients
that you want. Like that's so powerful. After I learned how
to cook for myself in earnest and building the skills to do
so. I'm pretty frickin happy with the food that I can make.
Now, I'm not trying to say I'm like a pro level chef by any
means. But for my imaginary restaurant, we're the only
customers me, I think I know my audience pretty well. We're
responsible for keeping ourselves nourished and healthy. So
I encourage you to find what works for you. This is your
life, and you can live how you want to. So try investing and
putting your effort and energy into this and reap the
rewards. You'll also at some point have to start thinking
about like real type adulting things, but I mean, like what
even really is adulting I guess it's just like being able to
take charge and like owning up to and like taking
responsibility for like your life stuff. You'll start seeing
taxes taking out a paycheck. And you'll like learn what a W
nine is and stuff like that. It's all like, honestly, I
think it's really boring and like kind of complicated, but
it's okay, we all figure it out when we need to spend an
afternoon googling, like, what is a 401k. And I'll tell you
like, you'll be glad that you did. That's one of those
things that if you do earlier on and you like contribute to
your 401k as early as possible, you really will get to reap
the rewards later on. And when you get like really confused
or overwhelmed by any of these kind of like adulty things.
Remember, it's okay to ask for help. The first couple of
years in any new phase of life, in my opinion is all about
growing and learning. Technically, you're never gonna like
stop growing and learning. But I think like in the early
years, like post grad is when it's like the most intense
because you're just building your own foundation for how to
do this because everything's new. Everything's gonna be a
little overwhelming, but that's okay, too. So there's
probably going to be times where you're like, I don't know
what I'm doing, but it's okay. You're not supposed to like a
lot of people don't know
what they're doing, especially when they're starting out,
you probably heard a lot of people say that because it's
true, like it's true. So really, and it took me like a
really long time to realize this. Ask for help when you need
it, like people like to help other people, like people love
to explain things that they're interested in, or they know
well, and like you get to benefit because you get to learn
from their life experiences. And don't worry too much about
like, if you're bothering someone, if you are, then they'll
tell you so like, don't worry too much. And just like go for
it. In fact, if you're in like a field or workplace where
you have a manager specifically assigned to you lean on
them, asked for like weekly one on ones and follow ups and
check ins as much as you want to, or maybe a little more
than you think you need to share with someone else that you
need help does require a bit of vulnerability. And I know
sometimes it can be scary, because it can feel like a sign
of weakness. But in reality, I think it's like one of the
strongest things that you can do. Telling someone your
worries can actually help to deepen the relationship you
have with them, because it's a great opportunity for you and
another person to really get to know each other and develop
a shared experience. So remember, you're not alone in all of
this. Life is not meant to be done alone. And there are
plenty of people who can help you out in tough times if you
ask for it. And this help is actually so important. Because
during this time, more than anything, the subject that
you're going to be learning the most about is yourself right
now is the time to learn who you really are. So when you're
going through this, like big huge change, you're probably
going to feel like all this like adulting. And like realness
is like getting thrown at you. And again, it's gonna be kind
of overwhelming. And it'll feel like a lot of things are
happening very fast. And to be fair it is. But given that
you get to design your own life, and you get to put your
energy where you want to, and that you can lean on others
for help. This entire process really is here to help you
learn who you really are, and what kind of life you want to
live through all the trial and error and like the mistakes
and like trying to get out of your comfort zone thing. Like
you'll realize what's for you and not for you. They're also
probably the things that you're like, this is not for me
right now. But maybe it'll be for me a few years from now,
these are all such important cues to listen and look out
for, because that's going to help inform you where you want
to steer your ship. So I think it's really important during
this time to make sure you're reflecting every so often on
your own feelings and experiences. Maybe you'll set up a
journaling practice to write your own thoughts and feelings
or a thought will randomly cross your mind while you're
commuting to work. Whatever the method, you will get to know
yourself really well during this process, doing this work
will actually make it a lot easier to deal with the ups and
downs of work. And then also make big life decisions when
they happen. And you know what self discovery process can
take a long time. It's normal to feel pressure to figure out
yourself overnight and to like know what you like and don't
like and what you want your career with life to be like, but
you don't have to. So it's totally okay, if you don't have
that figured out just yet. In fact, it's normal if you don't
like I mean, I'm, I'm still figuring out myself if I'm
honest. Like I just remember I felt like I needed to have
like a view or like an opinion on everything right after
graduation. But you don't have to like there's enough things
in our life right now that like create anxiety that we don't
have to add this huge like existential thing to our list. If
we don't have to remember how much time you really have,
like you have a lot longer than four years. So you've
probably noticed a trend in all these pieces of advice.
That's because it honestly all boils down to one thing. In
this moment, you've started your journey and becoming more
you than you've ever been before. Whether it's like the
people that you hang out with or the area you live or the
food you cook, or the type of career you have. You're in the
driver's seat, that is a seriously powerful thing. And
you'll soon realize adulthood is the best. So have fun
figuring it all out. Because you know what? It'll all be
okay.
Thank you so much for watching to the very end, and I hope
you liked this video. So I believe that one of the most
underrated tenants of adulting is to continuing to learn
even after graduation. And one of the best resources I found
to help you do that is Brilliant, who is the sponsor of
today's video. So you've heard me talk about Brilliant like
all the time, like they sponsor a lot of my videos, and I've
told you a lot about what their platform is and what they
do. In case you didn't know, Brilliant is a website and app
built off the principle of active problem solving. You learn
best while doing and solving in real time. So jump right
into solving problems and be coached bit by bit until before
you realize it. You've learned a new subject in STEM, so
It has actually upped their interactivity level on their
platform to a whole new level. Take this lesson about like
the Pythagorean theorem. For example, you might remember
from school what the formula is, but in this lesson, you're
moving around triangles and actually proving that a squared
plus b squared is equal to c squared. It's pretty cool
stuff. And I think I would have understood like all of my
STEM classes much better if there were stuff like this. And
you know what, there's more where that came from. So if
you'd like to join me and a community of 8 million learners
and educators today, click the link in the description box
down below or visit Brilliant.org/hellomayuko Alright
everybody. Thanks again, and I'll see you next time. Bye!!!
(Thanks for reading!)